tiens donc où on le rappelle la mesure
de confinement est stricte seuls
quelques sorties sont autorisés celles
non justifiées sont passibles d'amendés
est ce suffisant pour convaincre les
français de rester chez eux
nadège abderzak notre reporter laura
poser la question sur les champs elysées
c'est une image de la plus belle avenue
du monde qu'on a très rarement vu
d'habitude animé par ses différents
restaurants ses nombreuses boutiques les
champs elysées ressemble aujourd'hui à
une ville fantôme
très peu de riverains et encore moins de
touristes circulent uniquement des
véhicules pour la plupart des taxis ou
encore aides des bus est mis à part ceux
qui font leurs courses qui vont un
rendez vous médical qui vont au travail
qu'ils font du jogging ou encore qui
promènent leur chien
tous les français et bien sont dans
l'obligation de rester confinés chez eux
pour les 15 prochains jours au minimum
en cas de contrôle de police ils sont
dans l'obligation de présenter une
attestation sur l'honneur qui
expliquerait les raisons de leur
présence sur la voie publique et dans le
cas contraire ils se verront infliger
une amende de 135 euros
et bien je vous propose d'écouter
certains d'entre eux
et bien qu'ils ont pu sortir de chez eux
aujourd'hui j'ai le droit parce que j'ai
mon attestation et ma carte d'identité
je me rends chez le médecin pour une
visite de contrôle régulières dont j'ai
été contrôlé tout s'est bien passé
c'est dur mais c'est normal il le faut
je pense que pour vraiment comment dire
irradié 7 ce que 8,19 il faut vraiment
le faire il faut être il faut prendre
des mesures drastiques qui a pas le
choix
donc je tout à fait d'accord avec même
si c'est très dur il faut le faire à
chaud côté de chez moi
donc j'en profite pour faire un petit
peu d'exercice à l'extérieur parce que à
la maison c'est pas très grand et puis
on est nombreux
voilà mais faut sortir avec son petit
papier c'est très important parce que
surtout l'avenue des champs-elysées il
contrôle c'est bien après tout le monde
j'en vois ce qu'on respecte un peu les
consignes de sécurité de distanciation
de de confinement ce qu'il y a personne
à personne j'ai croisé 3 quoi je suis d
abord parce que je dois partir d'un
trois jours et étant donné que les
frontières sont fermées
vous vouliez aller
modifier mon billet mais mon billet je
fais quoi
ml oui donc c'est pas la solution
oui et mes vacances je fais quoi
attendez que j'ai déjà déposé des
vacances oui il faut expliquer que tout
est perdu
voilà moi j'aimerais bien qu'on nous
explique que quelles que soient les
choses tout est perdu pour faire
respecter ces mesures qualifiées de plus
drastique par christophe castaner le
ministre de l'intérieur cent mille
policiers et gendarmes sont déployés à
travers tout le pays
objectif ralentir cette épidémie de
coronavirus qui a fait 175 morts et plus
de 7000 personnes contaminées